is if you can still say it backwards she
forgot projects yes do you want to hear
it if you can if I can what do you mean
if I can said Mary Poppins smell naga
dosha Sallie XP istic tragic Ellie Rufus
what was good what's that I could I
never I'm pretty thick but I've never
understood the thing that Morgan Freeman
said to you that oh so when I was this
was about ten years ago I did a film
with Morgan Freeman it was a really
small film and the first 10 pages or 10
minutes of the film are us to just
driving together in a car and talking
and it took three days to shoot and he
didn't talk to me the entire times like
in between takes right cuz he had so
much dialogue I learned later right okay
so he was just you know so in between we
wouldn't really chat and but we were in
the car together for three days and then
at the end of the third day he just
turns to me and he goes Jonah Jonah Bobo
no banana fanna fo fona
me ma momona Jonah it was like super
uncomfortable I didn't
weird moments of my life and I just
didn't know what to say so I just said
thank you he said it was quiet again
then he said do me I was like do your
name and he's like yeah do my name and I
was like
Morgan Morgan Morgan me my mom Morgan
Morgan he went alright and then we never
spoke again
you forget your line you kind of go
you